Today we have sterling Anderson is the
cofounder of Aurora and exciting new
self driving car company.
Previously he was the head of the Tesla
autopilot team that brought both the
first and second generation autopilot to
life.
Before that he did his phd at Mit,
working on shared humor,
machine control of ground vehicles,
the very thing I've been harping on over
and over in this class,
and now he's back at mit to talk with
us.
Please give him a warm welcome.
Thank you.
It's good to be here.
I was telling Lex just before,
I think it's been a little while since
I've been back to the institute and so
great to be here.
I want to apologize in advance.
I've just landed this afternoon from
Korea via Germany where I've been
spending the last week and so I may
speak a little slower than normal.
Please bear with me if I become
incoherent or a slur,
my speech,
somebody flag it too and we'll uh,
we'll try to make corrections.
So tonight I thought I'd chat with you a
little bit about my journey over the
last decade span,
just over 10 years since I was at mit.
A lot has changed,
a lot has changed for the better in the
self driving community and I've been
privileged to be a part of many of those
changes and so on at the time with you,
a little bit about some of the things
that I've learned,
some of the things that I've experienced
and then maybe end by talking about sort
of where we go from here and what the
next steps are both for the industry at
large,
but also for the company that we're
building that Alex mentioned is called
Aurora to start out with.
There are a few sort of key phases or
transitions in my journey over the last
10 years.
As I mentioned when I started at Mit,
I worked with Carl Yani,
Mr Amelio for Zalia,
John Leonard,
a few others on some of these sort of
shared adaptive automation approaches.
Um,
I'll talk a little bit about those from
there.
I spent some time at Tesla where I first
sled the model x program as we both
finished the development and ultimately
launched it,
took over the autopilot program where we
introduce a number of new,
both active safety,
but also sort of enhanced convenience
features from autosteer to debit cruise
control that we're able to refine a few
unique ways and we'll talk a little bit
about that and then from there in
December of last year of 2016,
I guess now we started a new company
called Aurora and I'll tell you a little
bit about that.
So to start out with,
when I came,
no,
it was 2007.
The Darpa urban challenges were well
underway at that stage and one of the
things that we wanted to do is find a
way to address some of these safety
issues in human driving earlier.
Then potentially full cell driving could
do and so we developed what became known
as the intelligent copilot.
What you see here is a simulation of
that operating.
I'll tell you a little bit more about
that in just a second,
but to explain a little bit about the
methodology.
The innovation,
the key approach that we took there was
slightly different from what a
traditional planning control theory,
which we were doing was instead of
designing in path space,
uh,
for the robot,
we instead a found a way to identify a
plan,
optimize and design a controller subject
to a set of constraints rather than
paths.
And so what we're doing is looking for
Hamas certain environment.
So imagine for a moment in an
environment that's a pockmarked by
objects,
by their vehicles,
by pedestrians,
etc.
If you were to create the voronoi
diagrams through that environment,
you would have a set of each unique,
uh,
set of pads or hama is continuously
deformable paths that will take you from
one,
one location to another through it.
If you then turn that into its dual,
which is the dullest,
a triangulation of set environment,
presuming that you've got conduct's
obstacles,
you can then tie all those together
rather trivially to create a set of,
uh,
[inaudible] and,
transitions across,
switch those paths.
A canon can stake out sort of a giVen
set of options for the human.
It turns out humans tend to.
This tends to be a more intuitive way of
imposing certain constraints on human
operation rather than enforcing that the
ego vehicle stick to some arbitrary
position within some distance of a safe
path.
A,
you instead look to enforce only that,
the,
that the state of the vehicle remain
within a constraint bounded end
dimensional tube in state space.
Those constraints being spatial.
Imagine for a moment edges of the
roadway or circumventing various objects
in the roadway.
I'm a imagine them also being dynamic,
right?
So limits of tire,
a tire friction imposed limits on side
slip angles.
And so using that,
what we did is found a way to create
those hammad topis forward simulate,
uh,
the trajectory of the vehicle,
a given its current state and some
optimal set of controls.
Seek inputs that would optimize its
stability through that we use model
predictive control,
uh,
in that work and then taking that
forward,
simulated trajectory computing some
metric of threat.
For instance,
if the objective function for that,
uh,
minimize the or maximize stability or
minimize some,
some of these parameters like we'll side
slip,
then we'll side slip is a fairly good
indication of how threatening that
optimal maneuver is becoming.
And so what we did is then use that in a
modulation of control between the human,
the car,
such that should the car ever find
yourself in a state where that forward
simulated optimal trajectory is very
near the limits of what the vehicle and
it can actually handle.
We will have transitioned control fully
to the,
to the vehicle,
to the automated system so that it can
avoid an accident.
And then it transitions back in some
manner and we played with a number of
different,
uh,
methods of transitioning this control to
ensure that,
um,
uh,
that we didn't throw off the human
mental model which was,
which was one of the key concerns.
We also wanted to make sure that we were
able to arrest a accidents before they
happen.
What you see here is a simulation that
was fairly faithful to the behavior we
saw in test drivers up at dearborn in
dearborn,
Michigan ford provided was provided us
with a jaguar site to test this on and
what we did.
So what you see here is there's a blue
vehicle and a gray vehicle,
both in both cases.
We have a poorly tuned driver model.
In this case it pure pursuit controller
with a fairly short look ahead,
a shorter than would be appropriate
given this scenario in these dynamics.
Uh,
the gray vehicle is without the
intelligent copilot in the loop.
Um,
you'll notice that obviously the driver
becomes unstable,
loses control,
and leaves the safe roadway.
The copilot,
remember,
is in,
is interested not in following any given
path.
It doesn't care where the vehicle lands
on this roadway provided it remains on
inside the road.
Uh,
in the blue vehicles case.
it's the exact same human driver model.
Now at the copilot and the loop,
you'll notice that as a,
as this scenario a continues.
What you see here on the left is the
green is in this green bar,
is the portion of available control
authority is being taken by the
automated system.
You don't understand,
I've never exceeds half of the available
control,
which is to say that the steering inputs
received by the vehicle,
uh,
and end up being a blend of what the
human and what the automation are
providing,
um,
and what,
what results is a path for the blue
vehicle that actually better tracks the
humans intended trajectory.
Then even the copilot understood,
right?
Again,
the copilot is keeping the vehicle
stable as keeping it on the road.
The human is hewing to the center line
of that roadway.
So there was some very interesting
things that came out of this.
There were a lot of,
uh,
we did a lot of work in understanding
what kind of feedback was most natural
to provide a human.
Our biggest concern was if you throw off
a human's mental model by causing the
vehicles behaviors to deviate from what
they expect it to do in response to
various control inputs,
that can be a problem.
So we tried various things from,
you know,
adjusting,
for instance,
one of the,
one of the key questions that we had
early on was a,
if we couple the computer control and
the human control via planetary gear and
allow the human to feel a actually a
backwards torque to what the vehicle is
doing.
So the car starts to turn right,
human will feel the wheel turn left,
they'll see it started to turn left.
Is that more confusing or less confusing
to human.
And it turns out it depends on how
experienced the human is.
Some,
some drivers will modulate their input
space on tHe torque feedback that they
feel through the wheel.
For instance,
a very experienced driver expects to
fuel the we'll pull left when they're
turning right.
However,
less experienced drivers in response to
seeing the wheel turning opposite to
what the,
what the car is supposed to be doing
this for a rather confusing experience.
So there were a lot of really
interesting a human interface challenges
that we were dealing with here.
Um,
we ended up working through a lot of
that,
developing a number of,
uh,
sort of micro applications for it.
One of those,
uh,
at the time gill pratt was leading a
darpa program focused on what they call
the time maximum ability and
manipulation.
Uh,
we decided to see what the system could
do in application to unmanned ground
vehicles.
So in this case,
what you see is a,
a human driver sitting at a remote
console as,
as one would want operating and unmanned
vehicle,
for instance,
in the military.
Um,
what you see on the left top left is the
top down view of what the vehicle sees.
I should've played this in repeat mode
with bounding boxes,
bounding various cones.
And what we did is he set up about 20
drivers,
20,
20 a test subjects,
uh,
looking at this,
this,
uh,
control screen and operating the vehicle
through this track.
And we set this up as a race with a
prizes for the winners as,
as one would expect.
And I'm penalize them for every barely
hits.
If they knocked over the barrel,
I think they got a five second penalty.
If they brushed a barely got one second
penalty and they were to cross,
they worked across the field as fast as
possible and they couldn't.
They had no line of sight connection the
vehicle.
And we played with some things on,
on their interface.
We did,
uh,
you know,
we,
we caused it to drop out occasionally
we delayed it as,
as one realistically expect in the
field.
And then we either engaged or didn't
engage the copilot to try to understand
what effect that had on their
performance and their experience.
And what we found was not surprisingly,
the incidence of collisions declined,
declined by about 72 percent when the
copilot was engaged versus when it was
not a.
We also found that,
you know,
even with that 72 percent decline in
collisions,
uh,
the speed increased by,
I'm blanking on the amount,
but it was 20 or 30 percent ish.
Finally,
and perhaps most interesting to me after
every run.
Uh,
I would ask the driver in the,
again,
these were blind tests.
They didn't know if the copilot was
accurate or not,
and I would ask them how much control
did you feel like you've had over the
vehicle?
And I found that there was a
statistically significant increase of
about 12 percent when the copilot was
engaged in,
in that is to say drivers reported
feeling more control the vehicle,
12 percent more of the time when the
copilot was engaged and when it wasn't.
And then I,
the statistics,
it turns out they actually at the
average level of control that the,
that the copilot was taking was 43
percent.
So they were reporting that they felt
more in control when in fact there were
43 percent less in control.
um,
which was,
which was interesting.
And,
uh,
I think a bears a little bit on sort of
the human psyche in terms of,
uh,
you know,
they were reporting the vehicle was
doing what I wanted to do,
maybe not what I told it to do,
uh,
which was,
which was kind of fun.
Uh,
observation and then fund a,
uh,
I think,
I think the most enjoyable part of this
was,
uh,
getting together with the,
with the whole group at the end of the
study and,
and presenting some of this and seeing
some of the reactions.
So from there,
um,
you know,
we,
we looked at a few other areas,
uh,
my,
carl unm and I looked at a few different
opportunities to commercialize this.
Again,
this was years ago and the industry was
in a very different place than it is
today.
Uh,
we started a company called gimlet than
another called ride.
Um,
this is the logo may look familiar to
you.
We turn that into a,
we had at the time it intended to roll
this out across,
um,
you know,
various automakers in their operations,
uh,
at the time,
very few saw self driving as a
technology.
It was really going to impact their
business going forward.
They were,
in fact even even ride sharing at the
time was a fairly new concept.
Um,
that was,
I think to a large degree viewed as
unproven.
Um,
so as I mentioned december of last year,
I cofounded aurora with a couple of
folks who have been making significant
progress in this space for many years.
Chris urmson,
who formerly led google's self driving
car group at drew back now,
is a professor at carnegie mellon
university,
uh,
exceptional machine learning,
and an applied machine learning,
uh,
was one of the founding members of uber
self driving car team and lead autonomy
and perception there.
Um,
we felt like we had a unique opportunity
at the convergence of a few things.
One,
the automotive world has really come
into the full on realization that self
driving and particularly self driving
and ride sharing and vehicle
electrification,
our three vectors that will change the
industry.
Um,
that was something that didn't exist 10
years ago to a significant advances have
been made in,
um,
you know,
some of these machine learning
techniques in particular deep learning,
um,
and other neural network
network approaches in the computers that
run them.
And the availability of low power gpu
and tpu options to really do that well
in sensing technologies in high
resolution radar.
And a lot of the light,
our development,
so it's really a unique time in the self
driving world.
A lot of these things are really coming
together now.
Uh,
and we felt like by bringing together
and experienced team,
we had an interesting opportunity to
build from a clean sheet,
a new,
uh,
platform,
a new self driving a architecture that
leverages the latest events as applied
machine learning together with our,
um,
uh,
together with our experience of,
of where some of the pitfalls tend to be
down the road as you develop these
systems because you don't tend to see
them early on.
they tend to express themselves as you
get into the long tail of corner cases
that she ended up needing to resolve.
So we've built that team.
Uh,
we have offices in palo alto,
California and pittsburgh,
Pennsylvania.
Uh,
we've got fleets of vehicles operating
in both politics in Pennsylvania.
A couple of weeks ago,
uh,
we announced that a volkswagen group,
one of the largest auto makers in the
world,
hyundai motor company,
also on the largest automakers in the
world,
have both partnered with aurora.
Um,
we will be developing.
And are developing with them a set of
platforms and ultimately we'll,
we'll scale that,
uh,
our technology.
I'm on their vehicles across the world.
and,
and one of the important,
the important elements of building.
I asked lex before coming out here,
what's this group would be most
interested in hearing?
One of the things that he mentioned was
what does it take to build a self
driving,
you know,
build a new company in a space like
this.
One of the things that we found very
important was a business model that was
nonthreatening to others.
Uh,
we recognize that our strengths and our
experience over the last say in my case
at decade in chris's case,
almost hear a really lies in the
development of the self driving systems.
Uh,
not in building vehicles that I have had
some experience there.
But,
but in developing the self driving.
And so our feeling was if our mission is
to get a signal to market as quickly as
broadly and as safely as possible.
And that mission is best served by
playing our position and working well
with others who can play.
There's.
Which is why you see the model that
we've adopted and is now a,
you'll start to see some of the fruits
of that through these partnerships with
some of these automakers.
So at the end of the day are our
aspiration and our hope is that this
technology that,
that is so important,
the world in increasing safety and
improving access to transportation and
improving efficiency in the utilization
of our roadways and our cities.
I mean,
I,
this is maybe the first doc I've ever
given where I didn't start by rattling
off statistics about safety and all the
other things.
If you haven't heard them yet,
you should look them up.
They're there stark,
right?
The fact that most vehicles in the
United States today have an average on
average three parking spaces as spaces
allocated to them.
The amount of land that's taken up
across the world in housing vehicles
that are used less than five percent of
the time.
Uh,
the number of people,
I think the United States,
the estimate to spend somewhere between
six and 15 million people don't have
access to the transportation they need
either the because they're elderly or
disabled or one of many other factors,
and so this technology is potentially
one of the most impactful for our
society in the coming years.
It's a tremendously exciting
technological challenge and the
confluence of those two things I think
is a really unique opportunity for
engineers and others who are not
engineers who really want to get
involved to play a role in changing our,
changing our world going forward.
So with that,
maybe I'll.
Maybe I'll stop with this and we can go
to go to questions.
It's good.
Hello.
Thanks for coming on.
The question.
A lot of a self driving car companies
are making extensive use of lidar but
you don't see a lot of that with tesla.
One of the.
No.
If you had any thoughts about that.
The.
I don't want to talk about tesla too
much in terms of our specific.
Any anything that wasn't public
information,
I'm not going to get into it.
I will say that for aurora,
we believe that the right approach is
getting to market quickly and you get to
market and doing so safely and you get
to market quickly and safely.
You leveraged multiple that modalities
including lighter.
These are,
these are all just just to clarify what,
what's running in the background.
These are all just aurora videos of um,
our car cars driving on various test
routes.
Luke from the sloan school,
a lot of,
so a lot of customers have visceral type
connections to their automobile.
Um,
I was wondering how you see that market
to the car enthusiast market being
affected by avs and then vice versa,
how the,
uh,
how the ads will be designed around
those types of customers.
And thanks for asking me.
If I am one of those enthusiasts,
I very much appreciate being able to
drive a car in certain settings.
I very much don't appreciate driving it
and others.
Right?
Uh,
I remember distinctly several evenings
I,
I almost literally pounding my steering
wheel sitting in quogue and in boston
traffic,
you know,
on my way to somewhere,
uh,
I do the same in san francisco.
I think the opportunity really is to
turn that in turn sort of personal
vehicle ownership and driving into more
of a sport and something you do for
leisure.
I see it a gentleman sometime I go,
uh,
asked me to talk.
Hey,
don't you think this is a problem for
the country?
I think you meant the world.
If people don't learn how to drive,
that's just something a human should
know how to do.
A,
my perspective is it's as much of a
problem as people not intrinsically
knowing how to ride a horse today.
If you want to know how to ride a horse,
go ride a horse.
If you want to,
you want to race a car,
go to a race track or go out to a
mountain road that's been allocated for
it.
Um,
ultimately I think,
I think there is an important place for
that because I certainly agree with you.
I'm very much a vehicle enthusiast
myself.
Um,
but I think there is so much opportunity
here in alleviating some of these other
problems,
particularly in places where it's not
fun to drive that.
I think there's a place for both.
Yeah,
right.
You need to get
congratulations on the partnership was
announced recently,
I think.
Um,
so I have a two part question.
The first one is,
um,
so we heard last week from a,
I think there was a gentleman from bimo
talking about how long they've been
working on this autonomous car
technology and you seem to have ramped
up extremely fast.
So,
uh,
is there a licensing model that you have
taken out?
I mean,
how were you able to commercialize the
technology in one year?
Just to be clear,
we're not actually commercializing
distinguish,
we are partnering and developing
vehicles and will ultimately be running
pilots as we announced a week or two ago
with the shuttles we are.
However,
I will distinguish that from ron
commercialization of the technology and
I don't want to get too much into,
you know,
the nuances of that business model.
I will say that it is,
is one that's done in very close
partnership with our automotive partners
because at the end of the day they
understand their cars,
they understand their customers,
they have distribution networks.
Um,
they are,
our automotive partners are fairly well
positioned,
uh,
it provided they have the right support
in developing the self driving
technology,
the fairly,
fairly well positioned to,
uh,
you know,
roll it out at the scale.
So the second month,
my question is again,
looking at the you pace of adoption and
the maturity of technology,
do you see like an opensource model for
autonomous cars as they become more and
more
unclear?
I,
I'm not convinced that an open source
model is what gets to market most
quickly.
Um,
in the long run,
I,
it's,
it's not clear to me,
uh,
what will happen.
I think there will be a handful of
successful self driving stacks that will
make it a nowhere near the number of
self driving companies today.
Um,
but a handful,
I think
two questions.
One is in invariably new product
development,
there's typically two types of
bottlenecks.
There's a technological bottleneck and
an economic bottleneck,
right?
So technological bottleneck might be,
hey,
you know,
the sensors aren't good enough,
or the machine learning algorithms
aren't good enough and so on.
I'd be interested to hear and it'll
shift obviously over time,
so I'd be interested to know what you
would say is the current thing that if
hey,
if,
if this part of the,
of the architecture was 10 times better,
we would.
And then on the economic side,
I'd be interested to know,
you know,
jeff,
if sensors were 100 times cheaper than,
so it'd be interesting to hear your
perspective.
That's a great question.
Let me start with the economic side of
it.
And just to get that at the wake is a
little bit quicker.
Answer.
The economics of operating a self
driving vehicle in a shared network
today would close that,
that business case closes even with high
costs.
So sensors,
um,
that is not,
that is not what's stopping us.
And that's part of why the gentleman
earlier who asked,
you know,
should use lidar or not.
If your target is to initially deploy
these in fleets,
you would be wise to start at the top
end of the market,
develop and deploy a system that's as
capable as possible,
as quickly as possible,
and then costs it down over time.
And you can do that as computer vision
with precision recall increase today.
They're not good enough,
right?
And so,
so economically,
depending on your model of going to
market,
and we believe that the right model is
through a,
you know,
on the mobility services,
you can cost out your costs down the
center.
Inevitably,
you know,
there's no unobtainium in lidar units
today.
There's no reason fundamentally that he
should cost of lidar unit will lead you
to a $70,000
price point,
right?
Um,
however,
if you build anything in low enough
volumes is going to be expensive.
Many of these things will work their way
into the standard automotive process.
They'll work their way into tier one
suppliers and when they do,
the automotive community has shown
themselves to be exceptional driving
those costs down.
And so I expect them to come way down to
your other question,
a technological bottlenecks and
challenges.
One of the key challenges of self
driving is and remains that of
forecasting the intent and behave and
future behaviors of other actors both in
response to one another,
but also in response to your own
decisions in motion.
That's a perception problem,
but it's something more than a
perception problem.
It's also a prediction and you know,
there,
there are a number of different things
that come together to have that have to
come together to solve this.
We're excited about some of the that
we're using and interleaving various,
a modern machine learning techniques
throughout the system to do things like
project our own behaviors that were
learned for the ego vehicle on others
and assume that they'll behave as we
would had we been in that situation.
Like an expert system kind of approach,
right?
Yeah.
Uh,
you,
you assume nominal behavior and you
guard against all phenomenal,
right?
Um,
but it's,
it's very much a,
it's not a solved problem.
I wouldn't say it's very much as you get
into that really long tail development
when you're no longer putting out
demonstration videos,
but you're,
instead of just putting your head down
and seeking out those fine online's
yeah.
That's the kind of problem you tend to
deal with.
Yeah.
Um,
so this question isn't necessarily about
the development of a self driving cars,
but more of like an ethics question.
Um,
when you're putting a human lives into
the hands of software,
isn't there always the possibility for
like outside agents with malicious
intent to use it for their own gain and
how do you guys,
if you do have a plan,
how do you intend to protect against
that?
So security is a very real aspect of
this that has to be solved.
It's a constant game of cat and mouse
and so I think it just requires a very
good team and a concerted effort over
time.
Um,
I,
I don't think,
I don't think you solve it once and I
certainly wouldn't pretend to have a
plan that solves it and has done with
it.
Um,
we're,
we,
we try to leverage best practices where
we can in the fundamental architecture
of the system to make it less exposed
and in particular,
key parts of the system was exposed to
nefarious actions of others.
But at the end of the day,
it's just a constant,
um,
it's a constant development effort.
Thanks for being here.
Um,
so I had a question about what
opportunities self driving cars open up
since driving has been designed around a
human being at the center since the
beginning.
If you put a computer at the center,
what,
you know,
a society wide differences and maybe
even within individual car differences
that open up like cars go 150 miles an
hour on the highway and get places much
faster with cars,
be like,
look differently when a human doesn't
need to be paying attention and stuff
like that.
I think the answer is yes.
The,
and,
and that's,
that's something that's very exciting,
right?
So one of the,
I think one of the unique opportunities
that automakers in particular have when
self driving technology gets
incorporated into the vehicles is they
can do things like play with,
like differentiate the user experience.
They can provide services,
um,
you know,
uh,
augmented reality services or you know,
a location resilient and many other sort
of.
It opens a new window into an entirely
new market that automakers haven't
historically played in.
Um,
and it allows them to change the,
the,
the vehicles themselves,
as you've mentioned,
the interior.
Can change as we validate some of these
self driving systems and confirm that
they do in fact reduce the collision,
the rate of collisions as we hope they
will.
Um,
you can start to pull out a lot of the,
um,
extra,
you know,
mass and other things that we've added
to vehicles to make them more passively
safe.
Right?
Roll cages,
crumple zones,
airbags,
you know,
a lot of these things.
Um,
you know,
presumably in a world where we don't
crash,
there is,
there is much less need for passive
safety system.
So yes.
I have a question about the gullah nogo.
A desk that you conduct for certain
features.
Like you mentioned,
the throttle control,
where your slow down the throttle.
Assuming that the driver has pressed the
wrong wrong pedal.
When you test,
when you decided to launch that feature,
how do you know it's definitely going to
work in all scenarios because your data
set might not be censored.
It's a,
it's a statistical evaluation every
case,
right?
You're right there,
you will.
This is,
this is part of the art of self driving
vehicle development is you will never
have comprehensively captured every
case,
every scenario that is as uh,
my,
uh,
some of you may want to correct me on
this.
I think that's an unbounded set in fact,
have factory banner at some point,
but I think it's on.
Um,
and so you'll,
you'll never actually have characterized
everything.
What you will have done,
hopefully if you do it right,
is you will have established with a
reasonable degree of confidence that you
can perform at a level of safety that's
better than the average human driver.
And once you've reached that threshold
and you're confident that you have
reached that threshold,
I think the,
the opportunity to launch is,
is real,
and you should seriously consider it.
So thank you for your talk today.
First a,
and my question is self driving seems to
be able to ultimately take over their
world to some extent,
but just like other technologists today
that open up new opportunities but also
bring in adverse effects.
Um,
so how do you respond to fear and
negative effects that may come in one
day and specifically what do you see as
the positive and negative implications
of future day self driving
positive and negative implications?
So the positive ones,
I kind of listen and go find your
favorite press article on note list them
as well.
The negative ones in the near term.
Uh,
I do.
I do worry a little bit about the
displacement of jobs,
not a little bit this will happen.
It happens with every technology like
this.
I think it's incumbent on us to find a
good way of transitioning those who are
employed in some of the transportation
sectors that will be affected into a
better work.
Right.
Um,
there are a few opportunities that are
interesting in that regard,
but I think it's an important thing to
start discussing now because it's going
to take,
you know,
a few years and you know,
by the time we got these self driving
systems on the roads really starting to
place that labor,
I'd really like to have a new home for
it.
Hi.
Uh,
I'm kasha from the sloan school.
my question was more about your business
model,
again,
with partnering with both vw and he and
day and you just perspective on how you
were able to effectively do that.
Did not one of them want to go sort of
exclusive with you.
And what was your sort of thought
process about that?
So,
our,
our mission,
as I mentioned,
is to get the technology to market
broadly and quickly and safely.
Uh,
we are,
you know,
haven't been and remain convinced that
the right way to do that is by providing
it to,
as much of the industry as possible to
every automaker who shares our vision
and our approach.
Um,
we were pleased to see that both
volkswagen group,
uh,
and I'm assuming you all know the scope
of volkswagen,
right?
This is a massive automaker hyundai
motor,
also very large cross honda,
ikea and genesis.
They both shared our vision of how we
should do this,
which was important to us.
Um,
they both shared,
you know,
a,
a keen interest in making a difference
at scale through their platforms.
A volkswagen has a very admirable set of
initiatives around electric vehicle
electrification.
And few other things,
honda is doing similar things.
Um,
and so for us it was important that we
enable everyone and that was kind of
what aurora was started to do.
Hi,
I had a question now that I see a lot of
companies are coming up with self
driving cars,
right?
So most of the costs are pretty much all
the technology is bound only to the car.
So would we see something like an open
network where car communicate with each
other regardless of which company they
come from and what this in any way,
uh,
you know,
increase the safety or the performance
of vehicles and stuff like that.
I think.
I think you're getting a vehicle to
vehicle vehicle to infrastructure
communication efforts ongoing and that,
uh,
and it's certainly,
it's,
it's only positive,
right?
The,
it having that information available to
you can only make things better.
The challenge who's historically
bandwidth vehicle to vehicle and break
your particular vehicle to
infrastructure or vice versa,
um,
that it doesn't scale well,
one and two,
it's been slow.
It's been much slower and coming in our
development.
And so when we develop these systems,
we develop them without the expectation
that those,
that those communication protocol are
available to us,
we'll certainly protect for them and it
will certainly be,
you know,
a benefit once they're,
once they're here,
but until then,
many of the hard problems that I would
have welcomed 10 years ago to have a
beacon on every traffic light that just
told me it's state rather than having to
perceive it.
Uh,
I would have certainly use those 10
years ago.
Now they're less significant because
we've kind of worked our way through a
lot of the problems they would have
solved.
Sinky food talk.
My question is,
what's your opinion about cooperation of
self driving vr curse?
So maybe I think if you can control a
group of self driving because at the
same time you can achieve a lot of
benefits to the traffic.
Yes.
That is where one of the,
that is where a lot of the benefits come
from and infrastructure utilization,
right,
is in ride sharing with autonomous
vehicles.
And specifically,
you know,
the better we understand demand
patterns,
people movement goods movement,
the better we can sort of optimally
allocate these vehicles at locations
where they're needed.
So yes,
that's certainly that,
that coordination,
this is where,
as I mentioned,
these three vectors of vehicle
electrification,
ride sharing and autonomy or,
or transparent,
you know,
mobility as a service and autonomy
really come together with a unique value
proposition.
Yeah.
Okay.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you so much for a great talk.
Thank you.